>> MOMMA LOVES YOU JUAN,
BULLIES DON'T WIN.
I SAID BABY THEY DON'T.
BECAUSE WE ARE GOING TO GO
IN THERE AND WE ARE GOING TO
BEAT [BLEEP]
[CHEERS]
>> Tucker: DICK GEPHART IS
GONE FOREVER.
DEMOCRATS ARE BACK IN POWER.
SOME OF THEN LOOK NOTHING
LIKE THE DEMOCRATS YOU
REMEMBER.
AND SOME OF THE MOST RADICAL
ARE TAKING SPOTS ON KEY
COMMITTEES.
THE CONGRESSWOMAN RASHIDA
TLAIB YOU JUST SAW REEVING
THERE ON THE VIDEO ON THE
HOUSE OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE
JOINED BY ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ OF NEW YORK.
WILL THEY BE VERY DIFFERENT
FROM THE DEMOCRATS THEY
REPLACE SENIOR FELLOW LISA
BOOTH JOINS US FOR A PREVIEW
ON THAT.
>> HI, TUCKER, HOW ARE YOU?
>> Tucker: I'M MESMERIZED BY
THE TAPE WE JUST PLAYED.
>> EXACTLY.
AS YOU MENTIONED SHE WILL BE
ONE OF THE NEW MEMBERS OF
THE HOUSE OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE.
THEY HAVE THE BROADEST
AUTHORITY TO INVESTIGATE AND
SO THAT'S REALLY GOING TO BE
THE PRIMARY COMMITTEE THAT'S
GOING AFTER THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION AND TRYING
TO, YOU KNOW, SEE WHAT THEY
CAN COME UP WITH, RIGHT AND
JUST TODAY THE HOUSE
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE WHO IS
CHAIRED BY ELIJAH
CONSUMPTION SENT A LETTER TO
THE WHITE HOUSE SAYING THEY
ARE INVESTIGATING THE WHITE
HOUSE OVER THE WAY THAT THEY
GIVE OUT SECURITY
CLEARANCES.
SO THEY ARE LOOKING INTO
MICHAEL FLYNN, JARED
KUSHNER, AND A VARIETY OF
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION.
ELIJAH CUMMINGS HAS ALSO
SAID THAT THEY ARE GOING TO
BE LOOKING INTO THINGS LIKE
PRESIDENT TRUMP ZERO
TOLERANCE POLICY WITH
IMMIGRATION.
ALSO SCOTT PRUITT HIS TIME
AS E.P.A. DIRECTOR.
SO THE OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE
IS GOING TO BE INCREDIBLY
AGGRESSIVE.
YOU CAN SEE THAT TOO BY SOME
OF THE MEMBERS LIKE ARE
OF THE MEMBERS LIKE RRE
OF THE MEMBERS LIKE RASHIDA
TLAIB AND ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ WHO WERE NAMED
TO BE PART OF THIS
COMMITTEE.
DAN KILDEE WHO IS PART OF
THE STEERING COMMITTEE WHICH
IS THE COMMITTEE THAT
CHOOSES THE MEMBERS THAT ARE
GOING TO BE ON COMMITTEES
SAID THAT HE CHOSE THESE
MEMBERS BECAUSE THEY ARE
GOING TO BE AGGRESSIVE IN
GOING AFTER THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
>> Tucker: DO YOU THINK
THAT'S A PROMISE WE SHOULD
TAKE SERIOUSLY?
>> 100 PERCENT, TUCKER.
[LAUGHTER]
THINK ABOUT IT THIS WAY,
TUCKER.
SO THE DEMOCRATS ONLY HAVE
CONTROL OF THE HOUSE, RIGHT?
THERE IS ONLY SO MUCH
LEGISLATION CAN YOU REALLY
MOVE FORWARD.
MOST OF THE BILLS PASSED IN
THE HOUSE ARE GOING TO GO
DIE IN THE SENATE.
WHAT DO YOU DO AS A BODY?
THEIR OBJECTIVE IS GOING TO
BE INVESTIGATING THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
THIS IS GOING TO BE THE
PRIMARY GOAL OF HOUSE
DEMOCRATS AND, REMEMBER,
TOO, ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ, I THINK WE
HAVE THIS TWEET IF WE CAN
PUT IT UP THERE.
SHE PUT TWEETED OUT TO DON
JR. I HAVE A NOTICE THAT DON
JR. HAS A HABIT OF POSTING
NONSENSE ABOUT ME WHENEVER
THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION
HEATS UP.
PLEASE KEEP IT COMING JUNIOR
IT'S A VERY LARGE BRAIN IDEA
TO TROLL A MEMBER OF A BODY
THAT WILL HAVE SUBPOENA
POWER IN A MONTH.
SHE HAS PUT OUT THERE VIA
TWITTER WHAT HER OBJECTIVE
IS AS OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE.
THE TRUMP
TRE TRUMP
TRUMTRUMP
TRUMPRUMP
TRUMP AMP
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION SHOULD
BUCKLE UP A HOT OF NEGATIVE
HEADLINES THIS IS WHAT
DEMOCRATS ARE AFTER AFTER
THE NEXT TWO YEARS HERE.
>> Tucker: SETTLED THE
QUESTION OF WHETHER AOC RUNS
HER OWN TWITTER ACCOUNT